[Music]
you're my lassie come home
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm nikki novak
dogs they're person's best friend and as
we've come to learn through the years
they make great movie stars too from
animated to live action and true stories
to made up adventures dog movies have
proven time and time again
they can make you laugh they definitely
can make you cry
and make you hungry for spaghetti
you know what i'm talking about with
real digital and animated dogs being
considered today will bring you great
films that feature canines as main
characters or as the central focus and
while this list is truly remarkable we
will do our best to keep the dog puns to
a minimum and promise it won't get too
rough
[Music]
get it
okay
nine i'm done this is our list of the
best dog movies of all time
eight below
[Music]
and starting things off at just the
right temperature is the 2006 survival
drama ate below
directed by frank marshall this is a
remake based on the 1983 japanese film
antarctica which was in turn inspired by
the 1958 japanese antarctic research
expedition eight below adapts the events
from 58 but move forward to 93.
paul walker bruce greenwood and jason
big star in this story about scientific
explorers in antarctica who are forced
to leave behind their team of sled dogs
the animals are forced to fight for
their own survival while walker's
character searches for a way to rescue
them
the dog team in the film included two
alaskan malamutes named buck and shadow
along with six siberian huskies max maya
truman dewey shorty and old jack they
stole my baby names
[Music]
and because of everything that goes with
acting in a big hollywood movie like
having stunt doubles and stand-ins over
30 dogs lent their skills for this movie
oh to be on set
and at least five of those 30 had
previously honed those skills in the
cuba gooding jr movie snow dogs in 2002.
eight below carries the standard no
animals were harm disclaimer after
filming was supervised by the american
humane society but despite the movie
taking place in antarctica filming
happened in places like norway greenland
and british columbia canada in fact sled
dogs have actually been banned from
antarctica by treaty since 1993 after
evidence showed that disease was
spreading to the seal population the
more you know kids the more you know the
certified fresh eight below roughly
tripled its 40 million budget at the box
office and it was a hit with critics for
one big reason the dogs
like simon braun of empire magazine who
said walker and company might get a
healthy burst of screen time in the
middle but it's the team of dogs who
steal the show
marley and me hello puppy this one likes
you
clarence puppy likes you
well
that's your guy oh i was gonna pick you
anyway
don't tell anybody don't tell the others
get the tissues ready folks this film
was directed by david frankel of the
devil wears prada fame and it's based on
the 2005 memoir by john grogan also
called marley and me
owen wilson and jennifer aniston star in
the movie as newlyweds who move from
michigan to florida where they adopt a
super cute yellow lab named marley i see
i can't even get through this it's so
sad and despite the growing pains and
crazy puppy shenanigans marley becomes a
valuable member of their growing family
ultimately bringing out the best in
everyone filming took place mostly in
places like west palm beach and miami
florida along with a little bit in
philadelphia and since the film spans 14
years in the life of marley the dog 22
different yellow labs played the part
throughout the process and just in case
you're about to sit down and have lunch
one of the secrets to get the dogs to
lick a person or object on cue was to
use baby food
mash pees
i don't discriminate i love all food
as far as a big star like aniston
sharing the screen with a dog the
actress said that having dogs of her own
helped with not being afraid and other
than the younger puppies acting like
well young puppies the dog actors were
easy and fun to work you had enough food
marlin you've had two bowls of kibble
you had half a seatbelt in the car
how are you still eating
[Music]
she also recognized those seriously tear
jerking scenes at the end and said that
filming them was quote really hard and
she was bubbling over with emotion
same girl same we're still not over it
can you tell i'm angry
marley and me hit theaters on december
25th 2008 and ended up setting a record
for the largest christmas day box office
ever at the time a direct-to-video
prequel marley and me the puppy years
came a couple years later in 2011 and
while there's already plenty to be happy
and sad about with this movie let's
never forget that owen wilson and marley
were nominated for best lip lock at the
teen choice awards but lost to robert
pattinson and kristen stewart from
twilight at least they won for the
sloppiest kiss
101 dalmatians
there's no one out tonight
i'm afraid it's too cold we've got to
keep trying
being spotted next on the list is the
1961 classic 101 dalmatians
based on the 1956 novel the 101
dalmatians by dodie smith the film was
produced by walt disney productions and
marked the 17th animated feature from
the company
the story revolves around a litter of
dalmatian puppies that is kidnapped by
one of the most notorious villains in
animated movie history cruella deville
so she can make herself a fur coat
wrong cruella always been wrong will
always be wrong
betty lou gerson who previously served
as the narrator for cinderella provided
the voice for cruella and over talking
disney star power clarence nash best
known as the voice of donald duck for
nearly 20 years provided the dog barks
for this film i've heard it's good work
if you can get it 101 dalmatians ended
up being a box office success when it
hit theaters in january of 1961
and rolly you little roscoe did you
bring me anything to eat
everybody here
all 15. twice that many dad now there's
99 of us what
1999.
ultimately helping pull the studio out
of a financial slump after the very
expensive yet not so successful sleeping
beauty two years earlier
hard to imagine they ever had a slump
and one of the ways they helped save
money was by using cheaper animation
techniques including a copying process
called xerography for all of the dogs a
handful of re-releases have come in the
year since including in 1991 when it was
the 20th highest grossing film of the
year
and brace yourselves there's also been a
live-action remake in 96 and its sequel
in 2000 plus a direct-to-animated sequel
to this version in 2003 and a full-on
live-action reboot in 2021
oh that's a lot of pooches
critics love this very certified fresh
classic with a consensus that says with
plenty of pooches and a memorable
villain this is one of disney's most
enduring entertaining animated films
hachiko a dog story you don't have to
wait anymore
he's not coming back
all right
you do what you have to do moving on our
list of the best dog movies of all time
with 2009's hachiko a dog story
this is an adaptation of the 1987
japanese film hachiko managari which
tells the true story of an akita breed
dog who lived in japan in the 1920s
this film places the story in modern
america with richard gere starring as a
college professor who finds an akita dog
on a train platform during his daily
commute he ends up taking it home for
what was supposed to be temporary but
ends up forming a strong bond with it
while naming it hachi three different
akita dogs named leila chico and forrest
played the role of hachi in the film two
of which were adopted by a couple of the
film's animal trainers after production
wrapped
richard gere found getting to know these
particular co-stars a little bit more
challenging
admitting to feeling a little bit of
anxiety as he headed into filming
luckily after about three days of
shooting gear said one of the dogs came
over and put her head on his lap and
from there he was part of the gang gotta
love a happy ending
all right come here come here come here
come back
okay
it's all right
let's see if i can go all right
go home
despite a moderately successful
theatrical release in more than 60
countries including japan and the uk
sony pictures decided not to release it
in the us
instead the movie was released on dvd
and eventually debuted on the hallmark
channel
and since filmmakers were no doubt
expecting a spike in people wanting
akita dogs the end credits for chico a
dog story include a disclaimer about the
breed only being good for a dedicated
and experienced dog owner
good thinking and thanks to hachi the
fresh film has been fairly well received
by fans and critics alike including
alyssa simon from variety who said the
hatchies the central attraction
homeward bound the incredible journey
looking at him that night
he seemed so wise
and ancient
like the first dog that ever walked the
earth
and i just hope that one day
i could be like him making its way into
the next position on this list is 1993's
homeward bound the incredible journey
this is a remake of 1963's the
incredible journey which was based on
sheila burnford's 1961 novel of the same
name
the main character's names and breeds
were changed from the novel which takes
place in ontario canada ma home thank
you thank you while this movie is set in
california in the wilds of the sierras
and one of the main differences between
this and the 63 film is that the animals
actually talk in this movie who doesn't
want a talking dog it was directed by
dwayne dunham a one-time editor on
return of the jedi and follows two dogs
with lightsabers just kidding and a cat
that are dropped off at a ranch when
their family heads on vacation of course
they start to panic as pets tend to do
and end up setting out on their own
adventure to find a way back home and
those pets came courtesy of plenty of
star power along with the adventurous
bulldog voiced by emmy winner michael j
fox the cautious cat voiced by oscar
winner sally field and the wise golden
retriever voiced by oscar winner don
amichi in one of his final films before
his death morning honey
oh
dog breath
up and adam you too i found our
breakfast great i hope it's garbage no
even better with you two gourmets i can
just imagine shadow the bulldog and
chance the retriever sounds like chance
the rapper yo-yo were each played by
four dogs although a couple of good boys
named ben and rattler received top
billing for the roles and the other two
are still angry about it where's the
royalties and while dogs and cats don't
get along by nature the animals on set
which also involved 10 cats to play the
cat sassy ultimately became pretty tight
with each other and with the human
actors pretty much all the scenes where
the dogs interact with other animals
like a mountain lion porcupine and a
bear were filmed in cuts to assure that
no animals were ever in danger homeward
bound the incredible journey hit
theaters in february of 93 and had a
solid showing at the box office the
fresh film was followed by a not so
fresh sequel in 1996 homeward bound two
lost in san francisco with fox and field
reprising the roles as ralph waite
replacing don amichi
togo
meet elsa
try something with her and i promise you
you'll regret it
barking its way up the list is this next
2019 film togo this one was produced by
walt disney pictures and directed by
erickson core known for films like
invincible in 2006 and point break in
2015.
set in the winter of 1925
the movie tells the story of champion
dogsled trainer leonard seppala and his
lead dog togo as they set out across the
dangerous terrain of alaska to deliver
medicine to a small town during an
epidemic of diphtheria
and if that sounds like an impressive
thing for a dog it actually was which is
why time magazine voted togo the real
togo as the most heroic animal of all
time in 2011 dog bone drop
for this film togo was played as an
adolescent by a dog named riptide and as
an adult by a dog named diesel
diesel get this is a registered siberian
husky from newfoundland canada and a
direct descendant of the real life togo
going back 14 generations dude how cool
is that
[Music]
most of the dogs featured in toto came
from the snowy owl sled dog tours in
alberta canada where filming took place
in late 2018 and early 2019 and a couple
of good little pups from that kennel
named hugo and mackie were used as the
main stunt doubles for diesel the film
sticks to the real story for the most
part although it shows togo living out
the rest of his days with the main
character leonard while in real life he
was given to fellow musher in maine to
live out his golden years and sire pops
the good life of retirement
the certified fresh togo was released on
disney plus in december of 2019 and has
been a hit with fans and critics well
because
people love dogs and i love while i'm
default
the critics consensus calls it an
endearing and exciting underdog story
that benefits greatly from its stars
canine and human alike lassie come home
what's the matter lassie
[Music]
don't you want me to go i'll be out for
as usual
[Music]
fight well lassie lassie come home did
you think we were gonna leave this one
out come on the film is based on eric
knight's 1940 novel of the same name and
was the first in a series of seven mgm
films based around the dog lassie roddy
mcdowell best known for his roles in the
original planet of the aids film series
is the human star of this movie
alongside the canine actor named pal
together they tell the story of a young
yorkshire boy named joe who is forced to
sell his rough cali lassie and the
lengthy journey taken by the dog to get
back home to joe
the rough cali actor pal was the first
in a line of such dogs to portray lassie
in film and tv including starring in the
next six lassie films after this one
powell then appeared briefly in various
rodeos fairs and dog shows around the us
before starring in the last ctv pilots
in 1954
and then retiring but before his death
in 1958 pal sired a line of descendants
who would continue to play the character
for years to come now that is a biopic
i'm ready to sleep nice gail stay there
now don't you move come on come on
lassie
[Music]
come on
here
[Music]
lassie come home opened in theaters in
october of 1943 and performed well at
the box office it was nominated for an
academy award for best cinematography
color and best dog is there an acting a
word for best dog
and as icon status has set in through
the decades the film was added to the
national film registry of the library of
congress in 1993 and the character of
lassie also received a star on the
hollywood walk of fame that's what i'm
talking about just don't let your dogs
pee on it critic steven d greyjanus from
decent film says of this certified fresh
offering as old yeller is the classic
story of a boy and his dog lassie come
home is the classic story of a dog and
her boy
lady and the tram
oh how sweet
you like her darling oh i love her
what a perfectly beautiful little lady
[Music]
meeting in the middle next on this list
is the 1995 animated classic lady and
the [ __ ] the film was produced by walt
disney and based on a 1945 cosmopolitan
magazine story called happy dan the
cynical dog by ward green
the movie is about a cocker spaniel
named lady whose pampered life
disappears after her owners have a baby
and she eventually finds herself on the
loose
she meets a stray mutt named [ __ ] on
the streets who protects her and despite
their differences the two fall in love
the character of lady who provides the
primary point of view for this film was
voiced by barbara luddy who would go on
to voice merryweather in sleeping beauty
a few years later [ __ ] voiced by larry
roberts is a mixed breed that many dog
expert movie fans believe comes from
terrier ancestry the character had a
number of different names during
development including rags bozo and
homer before [ __ ] was chosen great
choice when it came to animating the two
distinct dogs animators studied a bunch
of different breeds to try to capture
their movements and personalities
similar to a practice that was done with
the deer for the movie bambi
oh
you poor kid
oh we've got to get this off
[Music]
i think i know the very place
come on one of the most if not the most
iconic and famous scenes from lady and
the [ __ ] is the spaghetti eating
sequins but it turns out it almost
didn't happen walt disney was thinking
about cutting it because he thought it
would look silly and not be romantic
luckily it was kept in and people in
paris are still doing this to this day
thank you walt the film hit theaters in
june of 1955 and performed well and
while it got some mixed reviews early on
the critical reception has grown more
positive over the years to go along with
the throngs of fans who just love it so
much including myself
a direct-to-video sequel lady in the
[ __ ] 2 scamp's adventure was released
in 2001 and a live-action cgi hybrid
remake came in 2019 as one of the launch
titles for disney plus
all right now be honest who's having
spaghetti for dinner tonight based on
what i just said
isle of dogs before we attack each other
and tear ourselves to shreds like a pack
of maniacs let's just open the sack
first and see what's actually in it it
might not even be worth the trouble
i don't know what do you think i'm not
sure maybe
hi
next up on our list of best dog movies
of all time is 2018's isle of dogs this
stop-motion adult animated film was
written produced and directed by wes
anderson who brought along much of the
same animation department that he used
for 2009's fantastic mr fox
the movie is set in japan and follows a
young boy's journey in search of his
lost dog in a place called trash island
where he makes new dog friends along the
way
the five main pooches in the film are
all named after some form of leader in
king duke chief rex and boss which is
very cool and the voice cast is
absolutely stacked so please don't hold
it against our editor if we can't line
up every name with every dog but here we
go the list includes
brian cranston edward norton leah
shriver bill murray jeff goldblum
scarlett johansson tilda swinton redda
gerwig france mcdormand courtney b vance
f murray abraham and harvey keitel
how about you chief
what was your favorite fruit
me
i don't care garbage trash scraps of
rubbish i'm used to leftovers
yeah of course i wasn't always astray
wait what'd you say
i said of course i wasn't always
wes anderson was partially inspired to
make this film after seeing signs for
the isle of the dogs a small urban
burrow in east london when he was there
making fantastic mr fox
very ironically so he combined that
inspiration with his desire to pay
homage to japanese cinema for the story
and characters and went with stop-motion
animation influenced by those classic
holiday specials from the 60s like
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer i guess
this is like the land with misfit toys
but dogs
to bring the dogs in their island to
life more than 2200 puppets and 250 sets
were made in various scales with some of
the detailed puppets for the main dogs
taking actually a few months to create
isle of dogs hit theaters in april of
2018 and went on to receive oscar
nominations for best animated feature
and best original score but lost to
spider-man into the spiderwurst and
black panther respectively
i kind of get it i kind of get it
spider and panther over a dog
what the rough
old yeller
and finally the last film on our list is
the 1957 classic old yeller
once again produced by walt disney who i
always took for more of mouse guy this
movie is based on the 1956 novel of the
same name by fred gibson who also
co-wrote the screenplay this story is
about a teenage boy in post-civil war
texas who discovers a stray yellow dog
on his property while his dad is away on
a cattle drive
despite not thinking too much of the mud
at the time the boy names it old yeller
and eventually the boy and his family
grow to love it because you know again
dogs the star of the film old yeller was
played by a dog actor named spike a
loppier yellow mastador which is a
mastiff and a labrador retriever
crossbreed along with appearing in
various films in the 1950s and 60s spike
was on shows like the mickey mouse club
and lassie
old yeller which was added to the united
states film registry in 2019 became a
vital part of popular culture for the
generations that were the baby boomers
mostly remembered as the first movie
that made people cry every generation
has that moment like when goose died in
top gun
[Music]
and along with its legacy for fans old
yeller is also a hundred percent fresh
on the tomato meter with a critic's
consensus that says it packs an
emotional wallop through smart pacing
and a keen understanding of the
elemental bonding between humanity and
their furry best friends
the success of that film led to a sequel
in 1963 called savage sam which was also
based on a book of the same name by fred
gibson but couldn't match the success of
the first iconic film well that's it for
the list and as i promised you hardly
any dog puns along the way i would say
under k9 for sure okay let me guess this
isn't the exact list you would have
chosen for the best all-time dog movies
the whole time i feel you so let me hear
you bark it out loud tell me your
favorites but for now it's time for me
to curl up into a little ball at the end
of the bed with a begging strip and my
favorite squeaky toy to take a nap
i mean it's time to go watch a bunch of
dog movies that's what i meant thanks
for tuning in to rt essentials i'm nikki
novak
bye
bye
[Applause]
[Music]